in just the same way that we integrated
twice to go from this acceleration to
this velocity to this displacement I'm
gonna have to enter it a bit further two
times to get from this acceleration etc
so someone help me out okay good
that was an easy integration okay how am
I going to deal with this guy using my
initial condition here alright so I know
that when T equals zero I worked out
with my diagram was the vertical just
vertical velocity was right so therefore
is 15 it's positive bonkers coming up
and so therefore y dot is equal to
what's that close to convey okay one
more time for a last one and negative
ten T turns into so this guy here is
negative five K squared
it seems a bit random but it all just
emerges out of gravity so you know two
thousand time you'll see this negative
5t squared the other third of the time
you'll see not ten be your starting
point by 9.8 bu standpoint so this is
gonna be negative four point nine T
squared okay so you only get these
coming up again again yeah Plus what
okay I bet it all blows up okay so now
just like before I said I wanted to
start at the origin okay so in 15-20 row
I've got oh no very cool displacement
and thankfully this lasted
okay have you got any color there let's
have a look at what I think we should is
okay I've got come up one three
equations for horizontal position and I
should also have you come up three
equations for medical mission okay it's
all set up and I highly encourage you to
do exactly what I just did now and bring
a new color in with you in the exam or
two in fact so you can separate what
these allow six equations sounds like a
lot kind of is but if you know what each
one is doing then you'll be able to move
with a real so this this is more for you
than for that welcome right so if it
pulls up in you highlighted or something
like that that wouldn't necessarily come
back unless it was yellow it would
complete the scale but again it's more
for you it's more for you because as I
work through these questions in a second
the most crucial thing for you is number
one which equation is am i working with
but you'd have to choose and number two
but what do I do with those equations
what am i solving for them to be equal
to sir what's what happens first natural
question if I started through it that
angle that fast how high is it going
today
now pause for it let's put forth have a
look at all your equations here write it
answering the question how high will it
go don't don't jump out because I know
so you already know the answers don't
you think which of these equations is
the most natural is the quickest path to
use in order to answer this
no I think I think the first thing we
can all say the first thing we can all
say is that we can ruled out these
horizontal equations of motion right
because I'm interested enough how high
so it's gonna be one of these two okay
now we could also rule out the
acceleration equation because it doesn't
really tell you much we just use that to
get the other two so then it's one of
these it's one of these so you could for
example say well the question is how
high that's a displacement right like
how what distance have you gone so if I
want to solve for that I want to know
the greatest value that Y will take does
that make sense
the greatest value okay that's one way
to go about it but look at this shape
look at this shape again it looks like
this so I'm trying to find this distance
here right this is a y equals something
okay
the natural the most natural way to find
where that is is to say well this point
right in terms of the vertical motion
what's happening at that instant in time
how is it moving in vertical terms
answer it's not moving at all like it's
gone up and then it first split second
it pauses it's not going up it's not
going down
and then it begins to drop so really
this equation here is the most natural
one to use
I want the vertical velocity to be zero
okay does that make sense so therefore
to find to answer this question right
but how high will they go I say at the
height of its motion by which I mean you
know the highest it will actually go why
don't is equal to zero right it's not
moving up or down at that point I
certainly can't move any further up
because it's at the fight and I don't
want it any further down so I'm going to
no just solve this equation what are we
gonna get here this is minus 30 plus 15
so it just takes a little bit of
rearrangement
what's the equal to yeah one and a half
seconds okay now this has not told me
the answer to the question how high will
it go this has told me when that happens
right so what am I going to do in this
then yeah I am going to finally use this
vertical displacement equation down here
okay so knowing that this is the time
I'll say when T equals one and a half
right the vertical displacement is going
to be and I'm just going to substitute U
this is minus 5t squared it's three or
two right so this is 911 four plus 15
times that 302 so we'll go ahead and
setting it so that's 11 and 1/4 meters
yeah 45 on four did I get it okay cool
by the way you'll notice it's a bit
unusual but I'm constantly converting it
to mix D rules do you see that rather
than leaving them is improper fractions
you don't want to say this to me why I'm
doing that you don't have to okay so if
I've got if I want to do some further
conversion or really if I just want to
get an idea of like 4504 what is that
actually equal to or forty five point
seven forty five whatever number you
choose right I'd like to get an idea of
the actual like I want to physically
understand what's going on and now mix
Niro's aren't perfect for that right